hello everyone thank you so much for
joining us this afternoon
my name is Madison Mills I'm a
journalist at Bloomberg quick-take we're
heading into July 4th weekend and some
people will be celebrating America's two
hundred and forty fourth birthday amid a
global pandemic protests over
institutional racism and extreme
unemployment rates in this country I'm
joined by opinion columnist Leonard
Pitts jr. and Noah Smith this afternoon
to talk about what the future of America
could look like given the events I just
described thank you both so much for
making time this afternoon and for
everyone watching please comment with
any questions you have for our guests
and I'll be looking at your comments
during the stream and can ask as many as
I can
Leonard I love to start with you I'm
wondering if you can talk our audience a
little bit through your thesis and your
most recent opinion piece for The Herald
yeah that was a peace theorizing that we
may be facing the end of the end of
America which is you know none not a
topic that you would ordinarily think of
intuitively for the 4th of July but it
felt like something that needed to be
discussed
essentially what I'm what I was doing in
that piece is dealing with the fact that
as a nation we are coming apart in a lot
of ways and I think none more critically
than the fact that we are coming apart
in a personal we're coming apart in the
sense that as Americans by the number of
measures we simply don't like each other
that much and it's hard for me to
conceive for getting the economic
pressures the racial and unrest the the
facts optional society we find ourselves
and all these other factors that are
pressing on us that the obstruction is
Congress all those other things putting
those things aside I just find it hard
to understand how a nation of people who
don't like each other go forward as a
nation so what I wanted to do was write
about the idea that we are facing an
existential threat fanned by our fire
current president and I thought it was
important to put that on the table
because it's one of those things that
you never really stop to think about
because it is so on first thought
on first blush so outlandish so beyond
the pale that you would never really
consider it seriously and I think that
there are some things that precisely
because they are frightening and beyond
the pale and so bizarre that you that
you almost owe yourself you know to prod
your self to think of them seriously I
always think of the September 11 attacks
and the fact that they're worth warning
of those attacks but the attacks
happened nevertheless because nobody
could conceive of airplanes being driven
in the skyscrapers it was beyond
imagination and I think that we owe it
to ourselves to you know maybe take a
second look at some of those things that
we deem beyond imagination to decide if
they really are absolutely you mentioned
this idea of people not getting along
with folks in other political parties
and no way you spoke about that in your
piece as well can you talk about sort of
the division in the country that we're
facing well I mean uh you know I'm I'm
not really an expert in in politics but
you know there's this this idea that
people have been that people with
different political preferences have
been moving to different parts of the
country that's the big sort I think was
the UM the research about that and I
mean obviously political polarization
has gotten worse and I think for a long
time people thought that that was just
an elite phenomenon and you know
Republicans and Democrats not
cooperating across the aisle but I think
at this point people realize that it's
more of a broad-based phenomenon of just
a bunch of Americans not really wanting
to live or share a society with their
fellow Americans and when that happens
you're not gonna have a country I mean
if you have if you have large
percentages of the people not wanting to
be part of the same country as as lots
of other people then that's you're not
gonna have a country actually you know I
do know a little economics about this I
just I recently wrote a column about
Alberto Alice Cena who's this guy he
wrote about how ethnic divisions which
is a euphemism for racism reduce the
reduce the provision of public goods and
also welfare and so of course in America
the example is that for many decades
Republicans have basically argued to
their voter base that black people don't
deserve welfare benefits and that public
goods like transit that
disproportionately would benefit black
people but would still benefit everybody
are not good and have denigrated these
kind of things like you know transit and
you know density and and other things
like that and so that really you know it
doesn't necessarily kill a country but
it really weakens a country a lot it
makes it poorer
we've got crappy infrastructure we've
got crappy transit we've got
single-family zoning you know we have
kind of this crappy patch together
excuse for a welfare state and we've got
all of these you know Republicans who
are who constantly trying to destroy the
welfare state by saying that the people
who benefit are deserving and so I think
that's weakened us dramatically and the
question is now will that will that
weakness basically replicate at every
level of society and just destroy our
country yeah what's from to piggyback on
that you just want to hear not what's
frustrating to me about this we are not
a nation that is in you know I mean
obviously we're having an economic you
know meltdown at the moment but overall
we are a nation with the wealthiest
nation on earth we are the most powerful
nation on earth we are the most
influential nation on earth so I you
know culturally and politically of the
most influential nation on earth so it's
just mind-boggling to me that with no
external threat that that you know that
really can can endanger us we
essentially choose our own demise
because we can't get along with each
other because we can't decide to share
the great and growing pie that is that
is American prosperity that's just
that's just an astonishing act of
self-immolation to me that I will never
be able to understand I hate you so much
I'm gonna kill us all that's really it's
really about it's insane and given that
do you either of you believe that we are
potentially heading to another so
well I it's funny you should mention
that because in writing that the piece
that I wrote speculated on the end of
the country I came to the passage where
I was I was speculating on what what
shape that would take and I was actually
gonna tiptoe around in Civil War cuz I
couldn't actually conceive of that
happening I couldn't conceive of Oregon
raising troops against Arkansas that
just didn't make sense to me and then
just as I was beginning to write I came
across this this prediction by Andrew
Church and he's included in the piece
who's a Yale University professor who
says that we could we could be headed
toward a civil war and what made his
prediction so astonishing to me and I
don't forgot his name right Andrew
Church in but what made his prediction
so astonishing to me was that this guy
ten years ago predicted that we could
see a period of great social unrest
quote-unquote around 2020 and you know
who and who in 2010 you know what a seat
would have said that so the fact that he
said that really kind of caught my eye
and I so I don't know I you know I don't
know I still have trouble conceiving of
you know one state going to war against
the other but on the other hand I've
seen numerous even before if we just
began today I've seen numerous
indications of law enforcement defying
governor's with regard to masks which is
an incredibly stupid Hill to die on
we've seen these people showing up with
long guns at the Michigan State House
again because of masks so it just you
know we're seeing a lot of actual and
implied political violence these last
few years which makes me say well you
know maybe right no I did you have
anything to add to that yeah I think
recently we've seen two major things one
of which is encouraging in one of which
is discouraging the discourage is what I
call the great police riot of 2020 we we
saw massive protests you know there were
violent protests but most of the
protests were peaceful and police really
attacked protesters a lot and and mostly
the ones they attacked were the peaceful
ones you know
and so that police riot you know some
people I know
gathered a webpage police abuses dot
info that just shows hundreds and
hundreds and hundreds of these extremely
brutal videos of police it was
nationwide it was just absolutely not
that's really discouraging because it
means that the police it confirms that
the police in America not everywhere but
in in many or most places have become a
lawless force and that's a really
dangerous harbinger of violence but the
good thing that happened the encouraging
thing was that the military refused to
stand in and take over for the police
Trump really tried to get the military
to you know attack protesters or you
know repress the protests or at least
you know stand in for the police and
they basically said no Trump's chairman
the joint chief of staff reportedly
shouted him down in the in the White
House and then a number of like major
active duty leaders and and and former
military leaders from all branches of
the service basically wrote statements
and issued statements in support of the
protests and so that shows that our
military unlike say Spain before the
Spanish Civil War our military is not
you know about to sort of enforce
trumpism or stomp across the country
smashing everything like it did under
you know Franco in Spain and that's
really encouraging because the military
has all the most powerful weapons and
and they're they have the most people
who actually know how to fight and you
know they have the real power and if
they are not going to do Trump's bidding
and if they support protesters and if
they have a strong commitment not to do
violence on the American people that's
really good and really encouraging
but the police are and you know and
maybe some militia people like the
people with the guns in front of the
state houses it's a different matter we
could I think a really bad scenario is
for there to be major violence between
left-wing and right-wing militias in
America you have seen some left-wing
militias in Oregon you saw a bunch of
you know people come into Oregon like
lefty
basically with with ar-15s to guard the
Chazz this sort of organized protests
that just ended in the middle of Seattle
you can see those people fighting the
people who are you know charging state
houses and you could see the military
stand back and say guys no stop but not
really doing anything to stop it and you
could see someone like Trump cheering on
the the rightest militias in this
inter-communal violence and I think
that's not too dissimilar to what's been
seen in a number of unstable you know
sort of failing countries so that's what
I worry about the most yeah I think the
other thing we have to take into account
is that there are people out there who
want this who absolutely want to bring
about this this great you know war this
cleansing or whatever you want to call
it the Dylan storm storm roof the
individual who shot up the church in in
Charleston one of his stated goals I
believe was that he wanted to foment a
race war and he's not and he's not the
only one so there are people who are at
you know forgetting or putting a
sidewalk there are social forces that
are pushing us toward this there are
individuals and groups that are also
actively egging that same thing on right
you've seen the the so-called Boogaloo
terrorists yeah they're these they've
been killing a bunch of cops in an
attempt to start a war it's not clear
whether the cops are going after them
but they've they've killed a number of
cops and then just a couple random
people since the start of the protests
and that's pretty scary stuff and can
this be reversed moving forward from
these traumatic events that we're
talking about and on top of that should
it be I think there are some people
particularly as we're heading into the
fourth there are black indigenous people
of color who would argue that this is
something that should happen that the
country is broken and needs to cease
well should it be I would say yes if at
all possible
I keep envisioning this epitaph America
was a great idea while it lasted the
problem the problem is not and I make
this distinction sometimes in my
speaking engagements the problem is not
America the idea America we hold these
truths to be self-evident all
people created equal life liberty you
know pursuit of happiness you're not
gonna get better those those are those
are great ideals they've lasted for a
long time the problem is that Americans
are nowhere near as good as America and
you know I think that what we need to
figure out what we need to do is figure
out some way to to to influence and to
push Americans to be as good as America
and that's you know that's where we have
fallen short for two hundred forty four
years and then where we are falling
spectacularly short you know this is Dan
I do believe that there needs to be a
great you know change and you know that
the things that we need to testing that
I don't want to use the word revolution
because I don't want the violent
connotations of that but on violent
connotations there does need to be a
revolution in terms of in terms of
changing the systems of this country but
I'm not I would hope and pray that that
doesn't have to happen at the barrel of
a gun because the thing that the thing
is that anything that you are forced to
do at the barrel of a gun you you will
ultimately resent and then whatever
change comes minutes if that's the whole
lesson of the civil war the side effect
the civil war whatever change comes will
always be tainted by the fact that it
was forced on you I would like to think
and I would hope that we can get our
people to do the right thing because
it's the right thing right no what are
your thoughts on that I mean we've had
episodes in America where we you know we
had some violence but ultimately we
reformed our system and improved it in
major ways without the need for you know
mass violence well I don't know without
the need but without degenerating you
know into into just complete chaos in
our country you know the 60s and the 70s
had you know there was violence in the
60s and 70s but ultimately there was not
a civil war you know and ultimately a
lot of reforms were made that I think
were good not all but I think that there
were a lot of reforms that were good
of like you know anti-poverty policies
you know in the in the 60s and 70s and
then I think that we you know we've made
major reforms before but not always you
know we had we did have one civil war
and we could have won again and so I
think we have the capacity to reform our
system into something that no one is
gonna very few people are gonna love but
I think most people can live with and
it's a little closer to those ideals
that we'd like to represent or we can
say screw it we're gonna try starting
something else we're gonna either break
up the country or try to you know start
a I don't know new constitution or
something and then I think you're gonna
you know that's that's a big roll of the
dice and not a lot of countries have
succeeded with that sort of roll of the
dice occasionally they do and a lot of
times they really don't I don't want to
become you know USSR too and I don't
want to become like Pinochet vol.2 I
don't want to become any of these these
sort of failures I'm naturally cautious
in terms of the political system because
I mean you know America is there's a lot
of people who have a hard time in
America but ultimately it is a you know
a richer more stable country than them
you know a lot of countries out there
those countries better than us but
there's a lot of countries worse than us
too so my natural instinct is to just
try to improve things instead of
scrapping it and starting it anew but
then again I don't get to decide yeah
and in both of your pieces you warn of
the overall decline of American
exceptionalism and we are heading to the
end of Trump's first term I'm wondering
if we can look back and starting with
you Leonard can you describe did these
issues start with Trump and if not when
and how did they begin they didn't start
with Trump but they Trump has definitely
been the accelerant Trump was definitely
the fuel on the burning on the burning
fire
this I traced this back to about 30
years when again the political right
began to decide that winning and that
holding power was was far more important
than doing anything you know and any
kind of bipartisan way and also when
they began to secede via Fox News most
infamously but other organs as well when
they begin to secede from the idea that
we all share in objective reality I
think those two things that that change
in Republican point of view and the
secession from from from objective
reality really were the the soil from
which all the rest of this has grown I
think news media have largely failed in
in their duty to be a watchdog on this
because we have been so concerned so so
you know obsessed with the idea of not
questioning even that which cries out to
be questioned that you know stuff has
been allowed to to to just sort of
fester and grow one example of that that
I'll give you is the 2016 election where
you heard it often said that both
Hillary Clinton and and Donald Trump had
baggage and I I've been telling people
for a long time yeah Hillary Clinton had
baggage and comparatively hers was
carry-on you know Trump was with steamer
trunks full of baggage and yet in news
media you constantly see would see these
efforts to portray them as to roughly
roughly equal in in their flaws and
roughly equal in the baggage which was
so intellectually dishonest it was it
was insane but that's what we did to
avoid supposedly showing favoritism so I
think news media have also played a
large role in this and then you know the
the the the elephant in the room the big
thing is the fact that the country is
changing demographically and that
there's a lot of white voters critically
on the right for whom that's problematic
and it was it was always sort of coming
and it was always part of the the
underpinnings of what was going on but
then this self-described skinny guy with
a funny name black guy with a funny name
was elected president 12 years ago and
that I think was the fire Bell you know
I can create from my
it's Jefferson not mistaken book the
fire bell ringing in the night you know
that was the alarm that frightened the
heck out of all of those folks and okay
the future that we fear is here and
we've got to do something about it and
now frankly as far as I'm concerned they
are in the position of trying to impose
what South Africa had before Mandela
came to office which is a nation where a
the racial minority controlled the
destinies and the quality of life and
whatever of the racial majority I think
they're there in other words a trend
rather than figuring out a way that we
can share power and that we can be
Americans and maybe even that we can you
know
align ourselves along different lines
other than just race I mean this class
there's there's there's poverty there's
all the rest of stuff rather than have
the imagination to do any of that they
are trying to take us back to America
circa 1954 or South Africa you know pre
Mandela and Noah you wrote that the u.s.
risks having the most spectacular
decline in history I'm wondering if you
can tell us are we closer to the end of
that scale at the end of that decline
are we somewhere towards the beginning
where are we in that one I mean the the
when we look at countries that collapse
you know that we're very rich and
prosperous and then collapsed we don't
have a lot of good examples which is why
this would be the most epic in history
but we kind of they all kind of end up
in the same place Venezuela
well not exactly same place some
established nightmarish authoritarian
regimes and others just slide into
complete chaos
so Venezuela we've seen a complete
economic collapse people are going
without food and medicine people are you
know there's there's unbelievable levels
of violence but they haven't really
formed a fascist regime yet in Venezuela
maybe eventually they will but then but
then it's really really bad and then you
know of course in some countries you you
have chaos you have a period of chaos
and then you have someone says I will
stop the chaos then you have this really
hardcore authoritarian regime sometimes
it calls itself fascist sometimes it
calls itself communist
sometimes it doesn't call it something
anything it just shoots a lot of people
and and that's uh that's another
possibility so you can just have chaos
and breakdown or you can have chaos and
breakdown followed by you know harsher
reassertion of authority by really
really bad people and yeah and I think
that both of those I mean you know venit
people don't like the comparison of
Venezuela because people just sort of
sputter at it they're like how could the
United States be Venezuela the economy
was all based on oil they were a poor
economy than us to begin with you know
they weren't this like great powerful
nation that we imagine America to be but
their decline was really really fast I
mean people were doing OK in Venezuela
you know 15 years ago and people are not
doing OK and Venezuela now um and you
know I mean I'm just trying to think of
like other modern examples where you had
this massive crash and you can't really
it's just it's just mind-boggling
um to think that we could descend into
poverty and chaos and violence that fast
if it does happen it'll be it'll happen
after everyone said that it couldn't
happen and sort of poo-pooed it and
dismissed it yeah and then also I guess
it could happen wasn't that spectacular
one for the history books folks yeah
that that's that's it exactly that in
writing my piece and in saying what I've
been saying for the last few years I've
sort of had this internal tension
between you know am I being too alarmist
and I've realized along the lines what
you said there know is that if ten years
from now we look back on this period and
we are fine is whele I would rather have
been too alarmist and not alarmist
enough yeah and that's what I'm alright
if I if it turns out ten years from now
on to alarmist I'll come on here or
whatever platform so hey guys I'm sorry
even I was bored that I miss read that
but I would rather that and look back
ten years from that and we were and
we're we're Venezuela is I say oops I
didn't you know I had the platform and I
didn't say anything
same yeah are there any other great
empires that have wobbled but then
recovered we've spoken of the opposite
impact
but are there any that either of you can
think of where there's there's been
wobbling and then a great recovery sure
I mean you have you've had some that had
revolutions and came out basically okay
after a lot of problems like France um
yeah you had uh I mean you had countries
that lost huge Wars I mean Japan and
Germany both got absolutely trashed in
World War two and now they're nice
places to live and you had you had
Britain which you know Britain really
went kind of downhill in the in like the
60s and 70s and people don't know about
it but their their per capita income
went down till it was about the same as
the Soviet Union and well the same as
Russia anyway and then they they made it
back somehow although you know not
without some difficulty I don't know it
it's it's hard to find a case of any
country as powerful as us ever and it's
hard to find a case of any country as
rich as us that's ever been and so it's
very hard to find a case of countries
that have been as rich and powerful as
us and then stumbled you can go back to
like Rome or something that's back in
the agricultural age everyone was a
farmer and you didn't have like you know
cellphones and so it's really hard to
compare and at least a couple of the
examples that you mentioned were of
we're outside forces acting upon the
country sometimes violently the thing
that I keep coming back to it's what
we're doing what's happening to America
some that we're doing to ourselves and I
can't see that that's unprecedented but
it's it certainly got to be you know
less president it let's say than some of
the others I think the best example
might be us actually we had two big
periods of violence that didn't end up
in civil war we had um in like the late
1910s and the 1920s we had this mass
explosion of racist violence you had
these huge you know put groms against
black people you know and just a whole
lot of violence you had the KKK with
four million members in a country of 80
million people just terrorizing towns
across America and and
somehow we ended up pulling out
ourselves out of that and and the the
KKK sort of fell and and we didn't
spiral into civil war I'm impressed that
we didn't then we had the sixties and
seventies and that also did not end up a
lot of people were scared that that was
gonna turn into like some sort of civil
war it didn't and we we ended up being
ok so I think we should look to you know
what we did to sort of to suppress sort
of the the the outpouring of racism in
the 20s I mean obviously we think it rid
of it but we sort of tamp down the the
biggest [ __ ] excuse me and then um
and then in the 60s and 70s we made
reforms to you know to set to to improve
the sort of situation that we were in
and so I think we should look to both of
those as maybe the possible examples of
how we could pull out of this and we
don't have a ton of time left so I want
to leave with two questions for you one
from our audience and audience member
asks how has the u.s. quality of life
gone down can each of you quickly
summarize that I don't know the quality
of life has gone down if we're talking
about you know two two iPads in every
home and uh you know in a car and every
in every driveway I don't think that you
know maybe no one knows better than I do
about this but I haven't seen any
particular precipitous decline in
quality of quality of life as measured
by consumer goods not that I know of has
that thought changed for you at all
given the moment we're in of
unprecedented unemployment and protests
and all of these things well I mean the
unemployment numbers have been so you
know so up and down that it's really
hard to get a read on what the long-term
impact is going to be I just read this
morning I guess we've had a huge I think
that unemployment rate is down which is
weird to say down to eleven point five I
think it is from from where it's been so
it's starting to come back although it
may see it yet another decline is this
latest coronavirus fight takes hold so
it's hard for me to in you know plus I'm
not an economy
so it's hard for me to predict what you
know the this latest thing this latest
situation awareness kind of is gonna do
to the quality of life in this country
know what are your thoughts well I agree
that I think that if you look at what
people say they're not they're not
really happy Americans are not very
happy in the last 10 years or something
you know just knowing that there is
unrest and knowing that a substantial
portion of the country out there hates
you is bad um in terms of quality of
life we've seen police killings really
skyrocket since especially since the
year 2000 they were going down for a
long time before that and then they went
way up and so all the people who are not
just victims of that but living in fear
of that obviously their quality of life
has gone down in one big measurable way
which contributed to the protests we see
suburban isolation our refusal to build
housing means that either you pay a
bazillion and rent or you live out in
the suburbs where you basically can't
interact with people very easily and and
are lonely and isolated and or both I
mean you can do both but then but then
rent has just gone way up our health
insurance is an absolute nightmare our
healthcare system is an absolute
nightmare and and when you know Obama
tried to reform it rush limbaugh got on
the radio and said that Obamacare is is
racial reparations and and the
Republican Party hasn't stopped fighting
against that since not to mention like
you know to say nothing of much better
health care systems like what they have
in Europe and so people just deal with
that the the horror and the expense and
the risk of that crazy health insurance
system all the time so those are some
ways that our quality of life really has
gone down even if we do have iPads in
every home and one minute quickly from
each of you I feel like we need to end
on a positive note do either of you have
hope for the future of the country and
what do you envision the path to that
looking like no I'm gonna leave that one
to you oh no you super quake one minute
sure a whole bunch of cities are doing
police reforms and not just little
cosmetic stuff but there are you know
doing big deep stuff right now in
response to the protests the military
told Trump to stop it we get rid of
Trump get Biden in their continued
reforms get a rational healthcare system
start building some more housing and and
basically the the Republicans realize
that their electoral strategy of like
making a wrinkle like you know angry old
right-wing white people madder and
madder and madder about the world is
just a dead end they shift they start
trying Republicans start trying to
appeal to you know broader cross-section
Americans and and then you know Kovac
goes away tensions like decrease over
the next 10 years maybe four maybe I
always struggle with the whole question
I struggle with it you know especially
now because you want to balance giving
people something optimistic with giving
people something honest but I will say I
agree with pretty much everything Noah
said and the one thing that I will add
is that what's given me over the last
few days is all these white people
sometimes in places where there are no
black people while walking around
chanting black lives matter this video
this feels like a moment then I frankly
never thought I would see so the idea
that perhaps they are starting to get it
and starting to be able to see the
humanity and people who do not look like
them which has always been the crux of
the problem the idea that maybe the
available they'll start to do that that
makes me makes me rather optimistic in
what is otherwise not a real optimistic
time absolutely well I can't thank both
of you enough for joining for this
incredible conversation we're very
grateful for your time and for our
audience please if you're watching
follow a quick take on all of your
social platforms wherever you get your
news Instagram Facebook YouTube and
Twitter and again thank you both so much
for joining we really appreciate it
my pleasure thank you